>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Javaka Steptoe's first book was
called In My Daddy's Arm I Am Tall,
African-Americans celebrating
fathers.
This actually makes a lot of sense
because his father was a
well-known author and illustrator.
Javaka Steptoe grew up to
become an author and illustrator
of children's literature
just like his dad.
He's illustrated many other books,
including Hot Day on Abbott Avenue
and Jimmy Sounds Like A Rainbow.
Javaka Steptoe's chosen form
of illustration is collage.
Are you guys familiar with collage,
anyone familiar with collage?
He constructs art by
combining common objects,
such as wooden blocks,
disposable plates, even pocket lint
with colored paper and paint.
Mr. Steptoe's newest book is the
2017 Caldecott award winning Radiant
Child, The Story of Young
Artist Jean-Michel Basquiat
which you can have signed
between 10:30 and 11:30 a.m.
in the book signing area.
So, without further ado let's give
a warm welcome to Javaka Steptoe.
[ Applause ]
>> Javaka Steptoe: Thank
you, thank you, thank you,
thank you, I am glad to be here.
How are you doing?
Okay whenever I ask a question
and somebody goes yeah,
I'm good that does not sound good.
You got to be like yeah, I'm good.
So, how are you feeling today?
All right, I like that, I like that.
So, I guess what I'll do is I'll
talk a little bit about the process
of creating a book and
then I am going to read
to you my book Radiant
Child which is --
what is a book called when you
write a book about an actual person
that has been alive
what is it called?
>> Biography.
>> Javaka Steptoe:
A biography right.
So, I'll tell you a little bit about
the process of writing a biography.
So, let's get started, first slide.
Is my presentation loaded?
No, maybe?
Oh, I have a clicker.
[ Applause ]
I'll tell you one thing when you do
presentations anything could happen.
Sometimes it's like really,
really, really catastrophic
and sometimes it's really
simple as pick up the quicker.
So, in my career I have
created all of these books,
I've illustrated some of them,
well I've illustrated all of them
and I've actually authored some.
Who knows what an author is?
>> You.
>> Javaka Steptoe: I am an
author, but I'm a lot of things,
so what does author mean?
Yes. A writer and who knows
what an illustrator is?
Somebody, you sir.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Draw pictures is that what you said?
Did I say it just like you?
All right, so that's my work.
Now this is a story my latest book
is called Radiant Child and it's
about a person his name is
Jean-Michel Basquiat and he's not,
well he is a regular
person, but he does something
that people love he loves to
draw and he loves to paint.
This is what a piece of his artwork
looks like and this is the piece
of artwork that inspired
me to create this book
about Jean-Michel Basquiat.
And one of the things that inspired
me was not only does he paint
with colors and use line
drawings and things like --
cool things like monsters and
stick figures, boxing and things
like that he also writes.
And only does he write things
that he makes up and comes
to his head he also uses history.
So, I find his artwork very
interesting and I decided
to write a biography about him.
Now the reason why you see this
little girl with her tongue out is
because when you write a biography
about someone you have to figure
out how do find out
information about them.
So, I like to say you use your five
senses right, so tasting right.
If they were a baker you would
definitely want to taste their food.
If they came from Puerto Rico you
might say what does Puerto Rican
food taste like and you might
taste it so that you get
to know a little more
about who this person is.
So, you had taste,
you have touch right,
you have smell, you have ears.
What do you do with your ears?
>> Hear.
>> Javaka Steptoe:
Hear and your eyes?
>> See.
>> Javaka Steptoe: See and those
are all of the different ways
that you can find out
things about someone.
You can listen to music,
you could see, read books,
you can watch videos,
there's all sorts of ways.
And then I found out something very
important after I found out a bunch
of information about
Jean-Michel there is a quote.
Jean-Michel said, I say my mother
gave me all the primary things,
the artwork came from her.
And the reason that this was
helpful is when you write a book
and you have lots of information
you just don't want to have a list
of stuff you want to have
story that is interesting.
And you know what, what do
you all think about a story
about a little boy and a mother
and the mother loves him so much
and inspires him to
become a great artist?
What do you feel about
that, is that a good story?
All right, pictures of Jean-Michel
and I'm kind of low on time
so I'm going to get
right into the story.
Somewhere in Brooklyn, in between
hearts that that thump, double Dutch
and hopscotch, a salty mouth
that slurps sweet ice there
was a little boy who dreamed
of being a famous artist.
In his house you can tell a
serious artist dwells as he sits
at his table with pencils
scattered everywhere.
Jean-Michel draws from
morning until night
with a serious face amidst a
storm of papers, refusing to sleep
until he has created a masterpiece.
At night images [inaudible]
in his mind as he wakes
from his dreams to
add one more line.
His images are not neat or clean
nor does he color inside the lines,
they are sloppy, ugly, sometimes
weird, but somehow still beautiful.
His art comes from his mother,
Matilda, a Puerto Rican woman
who designs and sews
and cooks and cleans
and makes the house look
like a fashion magazine.
But most importantly, she lies
on the floor and she draws
with Jean-Michel on his
father's old workpapers.
From her he learns that art is not
only in the poetry books she reads
to him or in the museums and
theaters that they visit art is
in the street games
of little children,
it's in our style and
the words we speak.
It is how the messy patchwork
of the city creates new
meaning out of ordinary things.
While visiting the museum he looks
at his favorite works of art,
reading the story behind
each artist,
each artwork.
This is how Jean-Michel learns what
it means to be a famous artist.
Back at home Jean-Michel
creates art on the floor
as his father Gerard plays
jazz records and his mother,
Matilda cooks aros compoyo.
Who knows what aros compoyo
is, what is aros compoyo?
Chicken with rice.
And she cooks aros compoyo
and she calls him mi amore.
Who knows what mi amore means?
Oh, you again, you got more answers?
What does mi amore mean?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
It means my love right.
How many of you know your mother
or your father loves
you raise your hand?
Oh, that's great, great, great.
And the energy and life
of the city can be felt
in each line of his drawings.
Jean-Michel soon learns that
art has a healing power.
After a car accident he
is scared and confused
and Matilda gives him a
book to calm his fears.
It is filled with skulls,
bones and other body parts.
Jean-Michel draws from it
until he learns it all by heart
and he is no longer afraid.
Back at home Jean-Michel's body
heals, but his heart breaks,
his mother's mind is not
well and the family breaks.
She no longer sits on the floor
and draws with Jean-Michel,
but stares out the window
singing only to birds.
Jean-Michel is confused and
filled with the terrible blues
as his mother must be
taken away to be cared for.
He tries drawing the
terrible out of his blues,
but things are not the same.
As he grows older he
visits his mother
when he can always bringing
his artwork to show,
telling her one day it will be in
a museum when I am a famous artist.
A teenager now Jean-Michel
decides Papa I will be very,
very famous one day with a sly
look, a twinkle in his eye.
Jean-Michel moves from Brooklyn to
New York City, the lower east side,
a concrete jungle where
the tough survive.
During the day, you know what I'm
so sorry I did not keep
flipping the pages I got
so into reading the book.
All right, during the day dressed
in a green jumpsuit splattered
with paint Jean-Michel stays
with friends sleeping on couches
and floors, leaving
a barrage of collages
and poem filled papers
everywhere he stays.
At nighttime Jean-Michel paints
the walls downtown with poems
and artwork that catches
the eye of artists,
gallery goers and passersby.
Underneath his artwork he sighs the
name SAMO instead of Jean-Michel
and everyone wants
to know who is SAMO.
SAMO moves from street
corners to art gallery walls
with powerful color, composition
and line collaging and painting
on everything he can find.
His artwork is still
not neat or clean
and definitely not inside the
lines, but somehow still beautiful.
With his magical charm Jean-Michel
draws a crowd, but when it's time
to work he prefers to be alone.
With the TV turned on and the
radio turned on full blast,
now in expensive suits
splattered with paint he flips
through magazines and open
books painting into the night
and sometimes for days
at a time as sounds
and images jump into his head.
Jean-Michel is an artist among
artists and he never doubts one line
and he moves to a soundtrack
that is all his own.
People describe him as radiant
and wild, a genius child.
But in his heart, he is
a king so he draws crowns
for himself and others he admires.
A grown man now with the art world
in his hand Jean-Michel still
visits his mother when he can,
but at the most important shows
above all critics and fans
and people he admires the
place of honor is his mother's,
a queen on a throne he
is now a famous artist.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
All right, I just want to let you
know while I was reading the book
and we got to the mother part
there was a woman in the audience
with the biggest smile on her face
and I'm assuming she's a
mother, are you a mother?
You yeah. Absolutely.
How did that make you feel?
Nice, she said great I
don't know if you all heard.
So, I think we have
like two minutes left,
so if you have questions
right now is the best time
to ask me questions.
So, hands up.
Oh, face me you can't just be like
hands up looking at somebody else.
What's the question?
Go to the microphone, there's
a microphone right here
and there's a microphone
right there.
Yes.
[ Inaudible Comment ]
I don't know about
everyone, but I can.
>> Okay, so I was [inaudible].
But I want -- oh, there you go.
>> Javaka Steptoe: Okay.
>> I went to [inaudible]
in New York and I want you
to tell them a little
bit about your journey
as to how you became a
children's illustrator,
as well as about your dad.
>> Javaka Steptoe: Okay, okay.
So, how many of you like to draw?
So, when I was your age guess what
I did every day, I would draw,
I would draw comic book characters,
I would make up my own stories
and I just would draw, drawing
was something that I loved to do.
And kind of like Jean-Michel
my mother
and my father were both artists
so I would learn from them.
They would always have paper and
pencils and crayons and things
like that for me to draw
and if I didn't know how
to draw a hand I would say mommy,
dad can you help me
and they would show me.
And so, I would just
draw and draw and draw.
I went to High School of Art and
Design just like the young lady said
and then I also went to college
for art and I also learned a lot
from my father because he wrote
and he illustrated artwork,
his name is John Steptoe.
I don't know if you,
some people are familiar.
So, they have the wrap
it up sign pointed at me.
If you want to ask other
questions I guess you could ask
when I step down.
But thank you for being
such a great audience
and I hope you enjoy your day here.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a
presentation of the Library
of Congress, visit us at LOC.gov.